literally I'm still in shock
I'm still in shock shortly after Chris
Brown was arrested on suspicion of
assault with a deadly weapon
Bailey Curran is speaking out on why she
called 911 or pulled a gun on her after
admiring some fine jewelry on display at
his home on Monday night I started
admiring the diamond cross necklace and
then his friend got a little bit crazy
and then that kind of triggered Chris I
think and said I'm getting so tired of
you people cussing me out saying get the
eff out putting the gun literally to my
face saying get the eff out now or I'm
gonna blow your head off
Bailey says she agreed to leave but
needed to get her cell phone which she
had initially handed over
I'm there waiting for my phone and then
the one friend goes back up gets my
phone brings it back out to me it was
very hesitant to give it back to me I'm
like okay why and then he's like me to
sign this NDA and I'm like I don't think
so I'm not signing anything so I then
took the phone from him and made a run
for it on Tuesday night Chris was
released from jail on $250,000 bail his
attorney took to Twitter insisting the
allegations against Chris our quote
demonstrably false Chris proclaimed his
innocence Tuesday morning posting a
series of videos to Instagram
I ain't did ain't going dude when you
get the warrant or whatever you need to
do you gonna walk right up in here and
you gonna see nothing